good morning Millennials I'm just I'm
taking the morning off what you can't
know I mean like when you work on and I
have literally the utmost respect for
you because you really co-host like with
not like with not me
so much more frequently than I do and
this is like the first time I've ever
really done it and it was really hard
it's it's hard you don't realize that
the co-hosting is such a hard job
talking straight for an hour like not a
lot of people can do them which is why
it's so hard for us to find to find good
subs but from what I heard there were
rave reviews you know it was all one
shake over it was all good but like I'm
exhausted I understand it was and by the
way we really do a very good job of like
there's a lot of work that goes into
like the toasts like the show
post-production like that and we really
divide it evenly right and then I
realize like how much there is because I
was doing it all alone and I was like
holy [ __ ] yeah it's hard it's hard but
I'm glad thank you for doing that for me
no it was a pledge and honestly I wanted
to was like you always do it and now I
feel like I did my part you have a deed
your part you let me I literally was so
out of the office later unreachable the
only time I had like I had such bad
service except all my Instagram's went
through which was the most important
priorities but I didn't even realize how
much I needed a vacation like remember
when we were talking and I was talking
about how angry I am like in the city
Margo took me to rumble I got my anger
out I was ready to move to pack up and
move to Cleveland
this vacation gave me a few more good
years in New York City okay so you're
like cowl rods well you have five good
summers left I have five good summers
left of and then I'll probably move to
Cleveland I need to figure it out but
when Carol said she'd five good summers
left was this summer the last summer is
that why she stopped the show is that
the correct math I need to find out when
she said Adam we're together for five
years I think it was probably three
probably was two more good summers after
this summer I didn't want to spend all
of her summers filming I guess that's
understandable yeah well we're back just
the two of us hey we had to make it if
we try we have such an exciting show for
you today we haven't so many
housekeeping and I don't even know where
to start
well I think we need to start with the
obvious which is merge day so honestly
this has been a project 365 days in the
we were supposed to launch our first
March in last October but because we
were under house arrest there were so
many constrictions but legal and
chammiya land Fiegel and fecal and it
was just so torturous matter and we
never got to do it but it was fine
because like we were living the dream
right and now we're living the dream are
doers yeah and we're in charge of our
own business and we knew the first thing
we had to do when we got this show off
the ground was March because you guys
have been asking for it for so long and
like you guys have been making your own
janky merch yeah and like using our
slogan looks like we're not gonna come
after you but now you can buy the real
thing yeah you got your counterfeit
merchant merch and I'm really excited
because I feel like like digital brands
like are always coming out with merch
because they feel obligated to they just
like to throw their logo on something
and it's like a shitty cotton t-shirt
but like our merch is premium look it's
funny obviously we have the classic
obviously first we have shitty our
regular it's even though that looks so
comfortable
okay this shirt is so epic like it's so
stretchy which like for anytime I put on
a shirt I literally like it's got such a
I got big boobs this is I believe a
large and it's just really it's a nice a
it's not fitted whereas that shirt is
more fitted if you're if you have that
kind of physique this is very fitted
this shirt is the I'm the Jackie on the
bottom tucked in you're the Klaudia
t-shirt and I have one obviously in
black that says I'm the Claudia you're
the Jackie so you and your bestie toasty
like need to purchase I was looking at
the comments on the picture that you
posted everyone was like tagging like
Jackie to there Claudia and vice versa
and I was like which ones I was like
looking at everyone's profiles like oh
you're so the Claudia like it was so
funny and the commence it's like if you
have red hair like you're obviously the
Jackie you might have a cloudy
personality right that's just wait works
so what would you say are some telltale
signs of the Claudia well if you've an
amazing singing voice are you just like
supremely talented in a certain trade
that would obviously make you a Claudia
but if you are just like drop-dead
gorgeous
that make you a Jackie or if you're like
you have a unique like look like red
hair that's you vote if you if you I
hope you are red head you're
automatically - Jackie yeah if you are a
dog mom you're the Claudia of course
you're a dog and speechless you're the
Jackie are you get are you getting the
point I feel like I've already knows
they're like an establish and this will
be really good because I feel like in
the past few years people have dressed
up as us for Halloween and it's hard
because like I just people like I'm a
Claudia like but she's just wearing
leggings you know it's like that's what
I wear and like a choker and a hat
but now it's like we made you t-shirts
and maybe around my Halloween time we'll
make like more specific like costumey
victims but so we have so many products
a few of which were wearing today and a
few of which we are going to show you
first
QVC style we have our pop sockets so pop
sockets which you know they go on the
back of your phone I'm using one right
now actually we have two maybe for the
man in your life the bro stir in your
life or the white one is just with our
plain logos super cute that's the one I
use Ben uses the black one with just the
text fact specifically asked us to make
black pops and so and he like always
needs when he's always watching [ __ ] on
his phone and I'm so excited
to make him my one yeah of course he
doesn't get one spring if you watch a
lot of TV on your phone pop sockets help
like the phone stand up on its own if
you take a lot of selfies from with a
long arm it helps you not drop your
phone especially if you're doing it like
over a body of water yep so or a mirror
a mirror pic it's super helpful it is
your phone just like doesn't shake it
just like chills in your hand you don't
have a claw hand you have like a nice
hand and if you have OCD and you like to
fit it a lot it's perfect for you I
literally never stop popping my pop
socket I mean and it never stops popping
for you that's such a good point and I'm
just really excited about this this is
like a staple this is called being in
tune with what's necessary we really
should have called it the being in tune
with what's necessary sockets because
fits on every iPhone any any Android
it's just like it's what the people need
and we gave them what they wanted you
know you're welcome so that's product
number one you know we're very into the
21st century we love tech gadgets gizmos
and gadgets aplenty i've got whozits in
whatsits galore
Chucky's do you want thingamabobs I've
got 20 but who cares no big deal I want
more and we have more for you next up is
a sticky wallet so this has an adhesive
back you stick it on the back of your
phone iPhone Android whatever with the
famous words I'm flat broke on the back
this is for some of our og brothers but
you don't even have had to have been a
brother to understand I'm flat broke
because if you're flat broke you're flat
broke and you know it yeah and like
there should be a credit card in there
but you might be flat broke so yeah it's
a mess your card
maybe there's a metro card and a single
or something honestly these things are
so helpful when you're going out because
some need to bring a handbag carrying a
purse is just not an option but these
days since I lost my license after
part with me everywhere and
unfortunately they don't make passport
sized wallets passport to Paris yeah
sticky wallets unfortunately maybe
that'll be in our next job I need a
passport keys I bought one from
Bloomingdale's and it was like miss saw
it was wrongly sized like I was shoving
my passport in there I have a certain
too clever one and it's premium cell I
have that one too and I like it but I'm
ready for anyone
I just fifty one this sticky wallet is
so cute I just love that we have like
inside jokes it's sparkly pink and it
has some white text so if you really
feeling flat broke I just think these
things are great and super useful but
they're always ugly totally you take
like a black one from like a free
charity event and also it's like there
are toasters abound we were just talking
about this in the group the other day
and you posted something like how it
must feel when you meet a fellow toaster
out in the wild if you like this mutual
respect it's like oh that's my people
now you just a flush your pops I'm
having these items it's like jello that
you are in tune with what's necessary
before they even know your name so our
next product is something I know our
tipsy toasters will get full use out of
and I just think would be inappropriate
if we didn't drop a shot glass so here
we have it a standard shot glass
standard sized I don't know what I'm
shot we're not trying that you know
please I'm a one-liter no no oh my god a
liter I don't know
it's chocolates and as the morning toast
on regulations its regulation size I can
just think of so many instances when one
would need to use this the possibilities
are endless the possibilities are
endless you obviously need to toast to
the toast with the toast it's all quite
toast ception yeah exactly
and the tipsy toasters I just know you
guys are gonna sell this [ __ ] out we
ordered extra stock of this one because
we had a feeling this would be a super
popular item and here's the thing with
the toast I mean sorry with the merch
anything that like does super well well
in like we're gonna make more where you
guys will bring back so you guys have
the ability to dictate your own future
and I just think that's really exciting
I think it's it's very exciting too and
this is just the beginning of so much
more merch and we have one more thing to
show you which is our actually to work
cuz they're both hats because cats are
so important if you have an oily hair
day if you're traveling yes you're
trying to keep it low keep your
celebrity which we know some of you are
ya know it's been like a major struggle
um we have come up with toasty hats for
you so this first white one has our logo
on it
still feminine but you know it has a
little pink in it but if you're a boy
you could still wear it
totally it's not a big deal it also
comes in black this hats they love and
they're all dad caps me posted a picture
of us wearing them a stick so good I
can't even with like big wide brim hats
they're so ugly like this is
form-fitting to a female's head and I oh
there are certain dad caps that are
almost too small and then your ears
poked out
this one comes right down to the ears it
has adjustable sizing in the back
obviously yeah I just have a small face
but it was like literally my dream size
of a hat you know it so funny cuz I put
it on this morning and I have to tighten
it I'm like wow I've never had to like
tighten something cuz I'm like I'm big
everywhere else but like obviously the
one thing that small is my brain god I'm
so lucky so that's super cute and then
it also was gonna come in a pink version
with a slightly different logo ya know I
think it's a same logo no this one
doesn't have the glasses oh this is cute
this is more like I'm a toaster and I'm
proud this is my go-to hat from here on
out you know how Biggie and Tamara these
guys will not be blinded by sunlight so
this one is super cute if you're like a
hardcore toaster you know how I'm in
housewives of OC Vicki and Tamra where
the hashtag housewife happy
yeah and hashtag toaster hats before
they have like spiritual gangster Thank
You Tamra where's but that's like lame
in basic if you don't wanna be basic do
you wanna be basic by toast no because
these hats are perfect it's like if you
don't know the toast and you're just
wearing like a cute hat and you do know
the toast it's like come say hi by the
way everything is super affordable let
me actually let me get the pricing cuz I
don't want to lie but we knew what like
we can't be selling 100 all or
sweatshirts over here people people get
out of I bought an ariana grande god is
a woman she was sweatshirt
when the song came out a month ago never
came and literally a hundred dollars
what and I but Kanye merch because I
thought it was cool I bought one for Ben
too and I feel like was a good
investment cuz it is really cool and I
feel cool when I wear it
but like out of control it was like $200
for me and Ben saying that's crazy
I bought me some grams emergency was
there yeah I still haven't opened it I
want to wear it on the show this week
and like but I want to promote our merch
first okay Muhsin Mason we're like on
the same level I want to pop socket
$8.00 that's that's pretty thats very
fair right there
in our apparel ask me how much one of
our perils oh the shirt I'm wearing how
much okay the prices aren't on here so
I'll tell you later but like it's all
super reasonable that's what I was
trying to say yeah we and we made it for
the average toaster and we're just so
excited about it thank you for
supporting us I hope you guys love it
we're and here's the thing we're
business women this is just the
beginning of merge so if it merges super
successful and it's something you guys
want to like keep like us keep designing
and having our designers we are I should
design you stuff hard these are some of
the basic things that you guys asked for
but some other teasers we have stuff for
the home we have a couple toasty posters
that like just scream college dorm room
and honestly I have to show you
something
I made them look I designed them on
Photoshop that's incredible and they're
so one of them is inspirational actually
they're both kind of inspirational
they're really good I'm just really
excited for you have a pillow mm-hmm
that is so cute I want it in my
apartment lots of cups because the
guzzle never stops and like because
these days you can't even get a plastic
cup right so are two straws and elastic
they're eco-friendly and sustainable but
they're not soggy paper straws so we're
all winning when we buy toast merge okay
um so here's here's what's up if you're
a patreon member but you everyone should
be you'll get access to the merch at
noon Eastern Time and then if you're
just a regular toaster 5 p.m. Eastern
Time we will open the website up to the
public um this is gonna be such a good
time I mean we're worried about getting
merch like it might be worth joining
patreon just for the month because who
knows I don't wanna jinx but I really
hope it sells out where it's the Wild
West out here you just never know what
the toasters are gonna consume and if
you buy merch and you're coming to camp
shows you'd better bring your merch I'm
bringing all my camp and if you're
coming to camp shows you get special
camp toast merch for free that no one
else can buy yeah there's ten what it
was it this time tickets left ten
tickets left to camp toast before we
have to close up shop and then we'll
start doing bunks so if you're waiting
to buy your ticket the last day you can
buy a ticket I believe to September 4th
so make sure to head over to a bent
bright it's in the link in our bio it's
everywhere like it is premium all caps
because like Premium you know yeah
because it's a premium experience
anyways thank you in advance for
supporting the toast and honestly I feel
like it's it's a good feeling to like
buy a pop second pop socket and know
that your $8 is being like reinvested in
a growing brand generally let me hire
the cosmetics this merch drop is like
the essentials but you guys have been
asking for
guys have been making on your own this
alert shop turns the lights on
yeah next sharply it's gonna be like
fashion you know toast that should you
guys buy it because if this doesn't sell
like um we can't invest any more money
right so if we're not use in work we're
gonna have to be out it's up to you how
things go the ball is in your court
okay we had so much to catch up on
besides merch which I'm still so jazzed
about what else did you want to talk
about why did you talk about camp toast
because I'm so excited oh my god me too
yeah it's really coming up I know we
also we're gonna have to make a schedule
for you guys of this show for the next
few weeks because camp toast is coming
up Labor Day weekend and Rosh Hashanah
so and I'm moving and Claudius yeah I
gotta prove my apartment right in the
nick of time
oh my god totally they could they have
waited any longer and you know what's so
annoying is that apparently the board
sent me a note two weeks ago just to
swap out one of my reference letters and
I never got it so we followed up we're
like hey was this approved she's like
did you see my note from two weeks ago
so I could have been approved two weeks
ago and that would have been so much
better for like furniture shopping I'm
so overwhelmed
this apartment is double besides my
current apartment and I'm not really
taking anything with me from my current
apartment and like four and I went
furniture shopping and like I'm here
like I'm joking
Claudia I was there and I'm I feel like
you are at least someone who enjoys
decor you watch him chip and Jo and like
you have an eye for home decor and I do
not and I was I was up to here I feel
your pain but I also think you're more
than equipped no I am but I'm I [ __ ]
hate there's nothing in this world I
hate more than waiting for furniture so
when the couch I wanted they she told me
12 to 14 weeks that's outrageous
I'm sorry especially if you're paying
for a premium you know what I read
online you with the markup on a typical
furniture is 300% that those are their
margins so we're paying a 300% margin I
could get my [ __ ] couch in one month
I'm so at it I've had it up to here with
the [ __ ] furniture industry
Restoration Hardware out of control okay
so me and then um last time we went
furniture shopping we went to Old
Westbury there's this strip of just
furniture they have a Macy's Outlet a
Bloomingdale's outlet it's a lot of work
it's like a full day and we went and it
was like somewhat successful it's just
like it's like not amazing stores then
to Saturday we went to the Paramus
Design Center did you know that was a
thing it's not really Center more of
like a highway but they had a West Elm
Restoration Hardware outlet even though
it's not the
everything just has like a period stain
on it and they literally take five
dollars off you buy it with the stains
you buy it with the same that literally
saw like a shits in here I thought a
skid mark on a capped and it was still
like 15 grand
I [ __ ] hate Restoration Hardware I
can't even begin to talk about it and if
I walked into someone's house and they
the couch them out like and again it's
cool about it's cool okay ready I saw an
exact copy of Bob's okay Bob's discount
yeah me and then went and went to go see
it it just didn't have the color I
wanted but I would have bought it they
have it up pops and they have it
literally had a million other stores
everyone copies ed and all the feedback
I've heard is that it's such poor
quality and I can you sit on it for like
a month and it's done I'm [ __ ] done
with Restoration Hardware so they had a
west Alma you just don't like their sky
like all their their stuff is like so
low to the ground me to the dressers
like I don't get it totally and then I
shot a couch from there but I'm so glad
I waited oh my god no you shall I went
to Mecca Z Gallerie Z Gallerie Mecca and
shout out to Jackie not you the manager
at the C gallery because she was a
toaster and she was just so helpful I
still don't get a couch but I'm gonna
call her today because have some
questions so wait West Elm I don't
really know a lot about West Elm I just
knew it was like expensive they had a
store not an outlet a store in Paramus
it was so reasonably priced and I
happened to be moving at a good time
because it's Labor Day and like last
week all the Labor Day sale starts like
the whole store was like 30% off and
like people were just making up prices
it was amazing that's amazing I went to
borrow New York City and I did not I
would do not find it favorable it's a
little too free people for me I'm sorry
shopping for furniture in New York City
like are you billionaire do I not know
about your billions I think we got our
furniture in Dallas I will I would
travel cabal coffee table in in New York
but it was it was a good deal
literally people who furniture shop in
Manhattan or a level of rich that I
can't relate to or furniture shop online
like that's where we got most of our
selves course waiting there CBT con code
coupon coupon cabin no coupon codes oh
so my mother last night and I have some
underground connects at Wayfarers so
sometimes they like shoot me discounts
but because this one was on sale they're
like it's most discounted it could be no
toaster she got in the mail lay a coupon
for 10% took another 60 bucks off Wow
and that way I was a I was okay to
purchase White Glove delivery yeah I
love wait they're after you
white klepto everything you think it's
oh my god you thinking that was a
headboard only a psychopath can and by
the way trusting me and Ben's weight on
him on a headboard that we built no do
you think that White Glove delivery is
like a luxury but it's not it's a
necessity and the luxury is done like
cleaning up and taking the packaging
like I could do that
yeah but then when they drop it at your
door I need to open all these boxes and
like assemble things you had a picture
TaskRabbit anyways just do white glob
you guys yeah white Club is premium and
there's only desert premium just like
there really are just like so many good
alternatives like online like all modern
Joss and main Wayfarer which are all
like the same parent company are just so
reasonably priced and I think it's just
like Restoration Hardware is setting the
absolute worst and by the way I've heard
that they're like a Ponzi scheme now
that I'm like a sports person against it
like I am a Leah Remini of Restoration
Hardware they have like weird financials
and like it really is weird that like
they're popping up because it really is
such a small amount of people who can
purchase from there like it's really a
luxury store have like their members
thing where and then you get like so
much money off I don't know how it works
but I feel like I know a lot of people
who have Restoration Hardware furniture
it's like everyone's go-to oh
interesting very interesting well Teddy
Mellencamp a DM to me that her husband
bought two couches and like she delivery
because they had like for like young
kids and two dogs and about white
couches without telling her and she's
like really upset about it she's like I
deliver haven't sat on it since we got
it six months ago
she sent me a picture they're really
cute Wow yeah we've become best friends
she also um DM to me that she supports
my grey movement she says because I'm
going between like a grey ambiance or a
beige and she said that beige is a
soul-sucking color and that I should go
with grey and that really put a lot and
just perspective for me yeah I wasn't
expecting that
I know well I'm I'm a Greg lady these
days I live in Grey Gardens
I can't even I can I would recommend it
cuz then you can like you get marble
silver lucite that's a nice scheme
that's what Ben wants you like who loves
marble that's why it works for Zach
tonight cuz we're both like soap in it
and this was the one thing we could
agree on but I'm much more of like the
nude beige pink gold granny vibe that is
much more my style vibe it is right you
should take these chairs totally by the
way when I was shopping for furniture I
found two Thrones so like we might need
to get really gonna up the Thrones no
cuz these are really good but those ones
were really cute too brony vibes but
yeah you know
what's will evolve I just know that like
one day when we become like huge stars
and like we'll be like the set will be
tech taken care of by the network like
we will still keep these chairs in our
like we each get one in our house yeah
this is I would do my makeup in the
office yeah this is what Kim Zolciak has
in her office she has such a cute office
even though like what did she do but um
yeah great well now that we've got in
the furniture out of the way good luck
with that honestly thank you um I think
it's time wait is it I had one I had a
list of things Oh Jackie that's not seen
to all the boys I've loved before and I
know that I have too and literally and I
felt so out of touch when the toast you
posted about you it happened overnight
no and you know what it happened the
night that I was traveling because I was
downloading stuff on Netflix for the
flight and I saw that movie and no one
had talked about it yet so I didn't
download it if only I had I would have
been so in tune all I know is that Peter
is is daddy and I've been avoiding
everything because I want to enjoy the
movie so I will watch it tonight
yeah no I really feel like you're I knew
nothing about it like I don't even know
that there was a person named Peter and
I feel like now that you know like
everyone's obsessed with Peter like it
kind of ruins movie for you but it's
fine
I was definitely ahead of the curve
because chemical laser was like you have
to watch this movie and I never really
taking movie recommendations but it was
like a slow day and I just did and I've
now watched it 17 times it's the most
amazing movie and the lead actress is an
Asian American and it's just a Netflix
like pioneering the way of progressivism
and it's like such a great time for the
Asian American culture because crazy
great agent oh wow and they're making a
sequel and now it's proving like you can
every romantic comedy starring an Asian
American people are just like so afraid
to do it but like look a lot of Condon
did it and she's killing it all so it
helps that there's absolutely nothing to
see in the movies all summer I've been
wanting to go to the movie to him and
it's like I can't even find something
that I could stand long enough to go so
I'm so excited we were crazy rotations I
know I need to see it my brother I pick
yeah
wait then I watched the kissing booth
afterwards and I was like this is trash
oh I know Jackie there's no question
that - all the ways I loved before is a
better movie okay if I don't watch it
tonight then you can talk about it
tomorrow Oh buddy for you I just like I
couldn't believe I was watching the kiss
he wasn't like this sucks
like it's so fake and stupid you could
tell that they filmed in South Africa
doesn't even look like LA yeah and also
we will be discussing tomorrow but just
because me too much to do today the
preppy connection which is our toaster
movie of the week even though it's going
on like three weeks now so if you
haven't watched it will give you one
more day to watch it and those web
should the reviews are in really yes it
is makes it okay you're gonna love it
I'm so well I downloaded it for the
plane I bought it on iTunes to rent and
then I saw it was on Netflix that I
could have just saved it and then I
opened my iPad and it wasn't there like
I didn't finish downloading family and
things before the plane gives me the
biggest I did it the night before though
I wasn't even like in the airport
because like I'm always in the airport I
literally had my Wi-Fi strong downloaded
all of these things season 2 a queer I
casino which is what I wound up watching
which was a very good been through movie
Casino I very much enjoyed it great
fashion um one more thing before we jump
in I know you wanna kill me but I saw a
play yesterday that I want to talk about
okay because it was called the band's
visit so his Ben's mom's birthing she
really wanted to see this play and I
like I'm not really involved in the
theatre community I'd perform I'm not
really you know teach and I said I'm
kidding but it was called the band's
visit I hadn't heard about it but
apparently like swept the Tonys it was
like the Slumdog Millionaire of the
Tonys and walking in I was like then
what is this about by that I use like
it's like Israel I'm like what like for
anything to be about Israel and I got a
pit you know because like everyone hates
Israel and I was like Larry googling
before I'm like man what the hell did
you bring me - I was like mad because
like when you when you something
mainstream that like the public likes if
it's about Israel it's always like it's
real sucks
we hate it's rock yeah so it was about
and first of all it has the most
wonderful message I can't okay so it's
about and it was so funny it was about
this is rip the Egyptian police band
orchestra police Orchestra they were
traveling to Israel for a concert and
that mean there's like um there's like a
like a NYPD has an orchestra yeah I
didn't know that it's like I don't know
that's right we're but there is like
there's an orchestra of like service
people I think like they made a band
within I don't know it's very
prestigious
okay is it is it specific to Egypt um I
think it's like a universal thing I
don't know now that you said it but it
didn't sound crazy when they said it to
me okay police orchestra makes no sense
to me but you're saying it really does
okay whatever they get to Israel they
have to take the train to Petach Tikva
but there's two cities in Israel one of
them is called Petach Tikva and one of
them is called bet tock tick ba so they
obviously go to the wrong one which is
like a literally a desert city with like
one building and that talkative is like
this cultural metropolis where they
invited
this Arab Egyptian band to come play
until like these 10 Egyptians like they
have to spend the night in this town and
then the play it takes the course over
like 12 hours of their night in the town
and it was incredible a because it
wasn't political at all but it was just
so harmonious it was like everyone gets
along and they come from different walks
of life and they just like they're all
people and they like to eat homeless you
know like it was so right but the best
part was that this band from like all
only two or three of the band members
were main characters and the rest were
actual band players and the entire score
for the play was these people playing on
stage they were like in the corner they
would put they were sitting on egg
crates not that crates crates you know
so it's way like they're just sitting on
a pile of sand yeah oranges yeah and
you're sitting on a crate of oranges
exactly and they were the most talented
I've never seen any and it was like um
Middle Eastern music like Lenin but all
played with like violins cello string
this weird guitar that I didn't know oh
my god the music was so crazy it was
unbelievable and then at the end at all
they went off and it was just like I
don't even like a work astre like
classical music it was epic like wow and
I recommend it it was a musical and it
didn't need to be because pretty much
nobody in the cast could sing and that's
hard for me like having perfect pitch
but it was just fantastic and they
captured Israeli culture so well you
know like the way that they talk and
they're just like so it was just like
yeah they didn't really it's a play from
Israel so like and they captured
Israelis perfectly and like being like
rude and dismissive it was so funny I
highly recommend Wow yeah okay I gotta
get to the theater but NYPD does have a
full band that's really cool
I'd love to hear them play the pipes and
drums you know like in parades
yeah I guess so yeah it didn't sound
weird man interesting I guess I don't
know much about the inner workings a
bunch of the police hobbies like that
this student he's fair and
extracurriculars I can't say the phrase
inner workings without being - inner
workings of my mind yeah also if today
is a podcast I recommend going to watch
online in like video form because of our
QVC style
promotion for our merch I just thing
it's not yet but we did talk it through
so yeah but you kind of looks like you
regress exactly now that we've
sufficiently wasted 25 minutes right it
is time to hang with
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
honestly adding the sound effect was
like just the best thing we ever done
right cuz I got a steal not much
happened this weekend which is just so
crazy I felt like I missed so much while
I was gone and now I'm looking for
stories and it's like nothing happened
which I think just speaks to like the
world in general like a news story is
when Kourtney Kardashian post an
Instagram at the same time as Sophia
Ricci no it's like that is news this is
what we always say it's honestly
mind-boggling how news stories these
days are just like someone leaving a
comment I do that every day no one cares
it's so crazy it is I'm trying to like
work around you know and not get caught
in these fake stories and like click
beep click beep ok never click mate
first story we never quickly first story
is Taylor Swift sings Tim McGraw with
Faith Hill and Tim McGraw in Nashville
you guys this is epic ok
superstar warmly embraced her Nashville
roots at Music City homecoming sheller
for reputation tour Taylor Swift
embraced her Nashville roots on the
Music City stop of her reputation tour
performing at Nissan Stadium the pop
superstar recalled how she and her
mother attended CMA Music Festival at
the venue as everyday fans soon after
moving to Nashville from Wyomissing
Pennsylvania that was us this past year
in 2011 she'd play a typically
abbreviated CMA fest on the big stage
but never headlined the stadium until
Saturday night bringing her spectacular
production including a massive video
wall to satellite stages and numerous
inflatable snakes the avatar of the tour
into the home of the Tennessee Titans
it's such a gorgeous stage I mean in
Stadium a really it's what the Nissan
Stadium and they literally have like
cars propelling from the ceiling it's so
crazy I'm like each gate is like Sentra
Nissan Sentra the Nissan Quest yeah
Nissan Quest remember when the Nissan
Quest saved our lives at the soup at JC
yeah yeah after the CMA parties yeah
words um wait I have so many thoughts on
this and this is the definition of in
tune with what's necessary also because
if you had asked me tell us what's going
to Nashville who should she bring on
stage I wouldn't have even had the
imagination to think of something so
incredible me neither I would have been
like Kelsey Bellamy right I have like
five thoughts on this my first is that a
little controversial okay
so if you watch the video Tim McGraw and
Faith Hill come out she brings out faith
first and feats
seems like a little all over the place
and then she brings out Tim who's hot as
hell
neither of them like knew the words and
I just think like I thought it was kind
of disrespectful like everyone just like
I feel like it's just so indicative of
how like Hollywood regards Taylor Swift
or like country music right
even though Tim McGraw was a major
country hit right and it's country
through and we're drove the song so like
for if it had been like anyone else been
in like had invited someone to such a
prestigious moment like very few people
get to headline the Nissan Stadium like
they would have been like knowing every
word I just felt like the lack of like
knowledge when it came to the song or
the melody obviously that and was so
obvious was like they didn't give a [ __ ]
you knew I mean III wonders I felt
disrespected like I did too and like
it's like to watch a video was really
embarrassing for faith because like
homegirl really didn't know the words
and like they're embarrassed but like I
would be so pissed I guess and I think
the generation they're like really even
when that song was on the radio like
they're much like of another different
generation but I don't think she took it
like a offensively no no I feel like if
they were like you know crying to diss
her they wouldn't have come on scene I
don't think it was a diss it was just
like I think it's just like oversight no
I think it's the eggs like that's just
like nobody in the industry like gives
Taylor's what the respect she deserves
because they think she's like a girl who
rates it out boys
but like if anyone else had invited I
think like Tim McGraw and Faith Hill
like they would have cared more about
knowing the lyrics do you know what I
mean I could see that but I feel like
Tim McGraw and Faith Hill are very much
like in their own world yes yes I don't
think it was intentional I just think
it's like indicative of like the greater
like the way that people just like
really don't have respect for Taylor
strip and they don't treat her like the
like the number one female artists that
she is and like she is comprar but like
what she's done in her career is
comparable to Garth Brooks and like it's
like bigger than Tim McGraw yeah and she
doesn't get that sort of recognition
also she's done it before the age of 30
right we're in like
girth Howell does she's on the same
level to me like cross-genre
as like Coldplay she has the same venues
as Coldplay as Beyonce and jay-z
together to people to fan bases like
nobody nobody talks about no but
especially like what she's done for
country music and like bringing like I
guess she's a math she is Beyonce
Lynette but I feel like she gets that
sort of a mutation because her tour
sells out yeah but like
and she doesn't get the respect that she
deserves in the country community also
like she writes one country song I'll
hear and it won every single award
better man I'm saying it in Nashville
and honestly when that song came out I
didn't know Telstra throat it and
anything Little Big Town does I
literally despise and like the song
sucks but then when Taylor Swift it's
like a really short video came out of
her singing it I'm acoustically at
Bluebird Cafe I was like oh my god this
is the best song of all time and then
she's saying it like in its obvious like
the way that she wrote it is not the way
that they sang it like the way that they
cut it but it sounds like one of her old
songs which it is and it's so good like
I really am waiting for the day where
she releases her own version of it
because it is so good but it's just not
the type of music she's releasing these
days but when she goes back to her like
fearless roots she'll release out so you
think that she will she she'll come full
circle
eventually I mean she's 30 she's
literally has ten more albums in her in
her life one of them has to become like
some what country need like a Joanne
moment for her like a stripped down yeah
just back to basics or you know what I
really want I want her to remaster
fearless because like it's obvious she
wasn't like working with the same like
caliber of production she's working with
now and the songs were like a little
janky if she rerecorded and breamast her
to everything like that would be epic
that would be or like a remastered of
Greatest Hits oh we could get a little
bit yeah I've speak now yeah a little
bit of red also the second point I
wanted to make is just the people that
were there Reese Witherspoon came Nicole
Kidman came with her kids and they took
such a cute picture Karlie Kloss Carly I
saw so Carly Clausen Taylor Swift
haven't seen each other in a year that
we know let me know if they haven't
spoken but Taylor does her own thing
sometimes you know but it would appear
as if they're not friends because Carl
accosted that hole swish swish Katy
Perry thing which is a Katy Perry song
presumably about Taylor Swift and
obviously you know what what the rumors
are about their lifelong friendship they
met up a tourist at your fashion show
then they were on the cover of Vogue
they just trips together all the time
people think that they're dating I'm
really pulling I just people say that
like as if it's a negative thing like I
think it would be one of the most epic
things of all time and I think the only
thing that could make me love Taylor
Swift even more than I already do is if
she came out as gay but like I'm not
gonna force her to be gay if she's not
but like I have a feeling she is like
I'm so here for it I just want her to
know like I think she's like afraid of
what people will think and I just
thought you don't know like it's epic
and I'm here for it so what do you think
Carly I heard show me I don't know so
this is just so confusing because also
everyone thinks dress is about Taylor
Swift which is that
oh sorry it's about Carly's like I don't
want you like a best friend only got
this dress so you could take it off and
she keeps saying that golden golden hair
blue eyes which is Joe all when her
boyfriend but it's also Karlie Kloss
just like I feel like they literally
tied his hair blonde so now I would know
and also when the song caught call it
what you want yeah I was like you're
saying Carly what you want yeah and also
um this is why we can't have nice sort
of thing it goes like this things huh
nee honey or darling darling whatever
there's a few different ones there's you
different and in one of them it sounds
like she's saying this is why we can't
have nice things
car leh Carly because you break them
just interesting and if there's tons of
conspiracy theories about it the one
that really got to me when I was at
first I'm like this is a crazy
conspiracy conspiracy and then I was
like then this one really put into
perspective I don't remember what the
song was orbital erequest but it's like
their love is um crooked not straight oh
and then I was like oh that's deep and
I've been analyzing her lyrics so much
and someone point look this isn't a
thing like she doesn't get people that
she's like a pop star like kids these
days know she's such a talented lyricist
she wrote alaric that's I saw it in a
meme and I was like holy [ __ ] and I
didn't realize what it was handsome
you're a mansion with a view mansion
with a view you're beautiful inside and
out like you know what I mean like she's
so talented and like people don't give
her the respect she deserves and I'm
pissed
I that's I agree that was my third point
I remember my fourth point was that okay
do you remember when we were in high
school
and like people there was a rumor it
would happen like every couple years for
someone literally rumored within New
York it would be like a cabdriver told
one of his passengers that there's going
to be a terrorist attack and literally
it would get to such a high level like
the mayor would have to address it
because was after 9/11 everyone was like
living in fear and literally school
would get canceled you remember that
yeah it happened like two or three times
we're like literally a rumor within New
York was started and it had like every
second is day they were like it's
happening in here right and it was like
it was real like that's what everyone
said and that is what happened at the
telescope concert because a secured some
girl tweeted that a security guard told
her that there's
huge surprise oh yeah there's a huge
surprise and todrick who was there as
Taylor's guest told someone in the prep
room like it's gonna be the craziest
show there's a crazy surprise and it all
starts with the letter K and this
[ __ ] rumor but why olds literally I
was in a thread I was refreshing Twitter
hashtag repped or nashville because
people were like they thought it was
gonna be Katy Perry or was gonna be
Conair Karlie Kloss or Kim or him yeah
like and I don't know how this [ __ ]
rumor got started but literally it was
amazing press for the show because I was
watching live streams a random man named
Shawn par he's a DJ like literally I was
watching like animate something epic did
happen but had nothing to do with the
letter came like the rumor was like the
security guard is like security but the
stadium's really upset Taylor because
like what she's doing is like so big
like they might not be able to secure it
and we were all like what because we
have a Stevie Swifty's sub group of our
toasters group I mean we're like what's
happening at some people were they were
sending videos like nothing happened and
but like that was literally like a rumor
about the terrorist attack that wasn't
what I was trying to make did to do
mindful circles I appreciate it I had
it's just so crazy like the things that
you miss when you're in your paddock
when you're gallivanting and then when I
came back like my vision was really
blurry I was talking about this on my
story yesterday I think it might have
been I was wearing these seasick patches
that like really helps with the
seasickness but apparently they I
couldn't read stuff on my phone so then
I was like not catching up on news or
anything so we were doing the glasses
that's how I felt I was like or like an
old woman minute today I'm better people
said I was just dehydrated and I also
had a nosebleed so I was probably just
dehydrated then like the that happens
when you travel like nosebleeds all the
time do you really I had never gone when
my life I was like what I want
I was watching Theo all day I walked him
home and then I was walking back and I
had to go into subway because I had like
blood all over my hand it happens at the
most inopportune time well shout out to
Subway for napkins and not judging me
coming in with a bleeding nose oh hold
on my dog walker um is there a bowl of
water I need to feel before putting Theo
in his crane it's in the kitchen
oh wow okay I'm gonna head into Story
number two because it's not new news but
it's something that happened while I was
gone and I really need your opinion on
it okay because Nick and Priyanka Chopra
enjoy a brunch date after returning from
India oh right so you have been mi a so
know Nick and Priyanka went to India hmm
how do they get apart it hadn't get from
tree they brought the parents into it
they brought the religion into it then
they also went to LA and have like a
la like cool Hollywood right it soon
they are going like balls to the walls
on this so what Taylor's checker and I
said because we were both convinced at
its fake bore like this is an extreme
lengths to go to right similar what my
analogy I'm all about analogies these
days my analogy was like people say
Carly closes gay and Jared Kushner is
her beard but why are they getting
married like that's like you're taking
your beard inist to the next uh but you
don't get married so what we were just
like maybe it's not fake like it really
was making me second-guess but obviously
and he puts everything into perspective
cuz he did a blind about them right and
what he said was that she now got a role
in Avengers Marvel which like you make
Bank on and she was completely looked
over for it before all this happened and
now that it's happening it like it
basically it worked
yeah so she's going even more full
throttle throwing herself fooling into
this fake relationship because it's been
hard for her I wonder if it's good for
Nick's career I don't know he just
released a new song did a lot of people
listen to it I do not know I still I
don't listen I still think that it's
fake but honestly I respect the hustle
of course and I'm sure everyone has
their reasons for doing what they do
Carly and Josh Kushner whatever even
though they dated for so long that like
they would have had to engage we didn't
seem far-fetched but this was like so
publicity thirsty right but you know
what if it's working for you fine like
whatever we get to see more Nick Jonas
and talk about him I'm so much did you
see that video of them singing Love Bug
no so when they went to the other did
like uh like some some other activities
when the activities was visiting this
orphanage and they both sat they both
sat on a chair Jack and they were
sharing a chair like so stupid and he's
saying lovebug and all the kids were
like loving in like that part was cute
but like she didn't know the words
Priyanka she was just like looking at
him and she was like and I'm it [ __ ]
you know but like if you know that song
you're [ __ ] singing it lovebug again
I mean I would never take her as a Jonas
Brothers ass speechless and honestly her
PR team is like working so overtime like
they should have gotten her to learn
some of the lyrics but like when the
Jonas Brothers were popping off like
where was Priyanka like she was like in
college yeah she was setting for
Quantico right like I can't with this
and people like enews is like giving
them what they want and it's annoying
no it
and the fact that I no one watches this
show so can you stop like perpetuating
this fake relationship because then they
think they're doing it right and that
it's working and so they'll continue to
do it but it's not even a news as fault
now it's Marvel's fault for dignifying
this relationship with the role you know
and like while I'm happy for Marvel cuz
like they've been really slow to move
into like the 21st century and like one
of their leads now being like Indian is
wonderful but like it's based off of a
fake publicity and like therefore it's
not real I like I just anytime I see
them it's like it makes no [ __ ] sense
and like the sharing of the chair like
that was just like that was it for me
look it there was another channel like
they brought the parents into it there
are orphans into it like that's not cool
but they brought like like Frankie Jonas
into it like that's crazy
justice for Frankie Jonas dude he gets
to get a bonus Jonas right to see you
like get a nine-to-five maybe he works
for the family you know yeah because the
dad was their manager right yeah so
maybe he's like the dad recently got
sick yeah maybe you know who I like who
Danielle Jonas yeah she seems like a
good girl we have the same wedding
planner do you Mikey did their wedding
like today had a reality show like I
feel like she's getting the perks of
like being a Jonas but like also gets a
normal life and she seems like a really
down-to-earth girl I think before they
met like she was a hairdresser like she
doesn't seem like it's really changed
her she was in a huge house now but like
did it they did celebrity right yeah and
like I just feel like I've met their
daughter she's so cute did you meet
their daughter um I went to a kid's
birthday party of one of my friends and
the kids are friends so Kevin brought
her he was like a single dad like out on
the on the town and they were just her
mom I was 11 11 Mukesh I'm wishing for
something tangible I hope all the merge
cells well that won't come true
and I'm trying to Kim to us now I used
to make like all these grand wishes like
you know health wealth prosperity world
peace but it's like I'll never knoweth
is that worked or not Chucky so I'm
having my dementia I talked about this
yeah I felt like I might have but so now
I wish for really specific things yeah
no toast more chilling out like I hope I
lose two pounds this week and I'm not
I'm not I'm gonna hear for the not
telling your - your wish thing really
yeah that's definitely like a lie and to
the casue position and Jews are not
supposed to be superstitious that's true
okay I'm walking under all the ladders
today anyways I'm continuing
Nick and Priyanka but I just wanted like
give them kudos for really taking this
thing all the way like they will stop at
nothing and they will get married I
think you need to get um to know Jonas
on the show and just like be ready to
read questions about Nick and Priyanka
and excited so Nick Jonas is like Megan
Markel is gonna be at Nick Jonas his
wedding because Megan and Priyanka are
best friends
oh my god great call Prince Harry's
gonna be at Nick Jonas wedding no no
he's on but what Megan's gonna go stag
Oprah Terry sorry they members William
yeah actually she might go stag but like
like that's a security concern for Harry
but like no one cares about Megan cuz
she's like not a blood he's having like
a really hard week I know she's having
like a hard time the I just saw an
article on a that these were her first
100 days as a royal and like they were
not they were not I like really tell
she's losing so much weight and like she
definitely was super skinny but like now
it's at the point where she's losing
weight by accident yeah and like I don't
know what that's like because I've never
had that I had the opposite like if I
don't think something traumatic I can't
stop eating I feel like the same thing
happened to Kate though when like right
after she got married she got like so
skinny it must be so stressful and
there's so much pressure on them to get
pregnant and to get pregnant when you're
that skinny is like impossible but then
you know what Angie says that they have
a surrogate so well whatever royal
sergeant um I wonder how much she gets
paid like became surrogacy the news
about Kim I know but it's like fake
alright oh yeah do you have an embryo
and they'll probably will use it yes it
had that that's what I'm saying to Ben
and he didn't agree with me like Kim is
like that type of mom we're like she's
like there's never enough she's never
gonna have enough kids like she's just
always like she really is like a devoted
mom and I think Courtney's the same way
I think Chloe will be the same way
anything it's just cuz that's the family
they grew up in like they raised six
siblings I thought you were the same
will be the same way to call but I can
agree with me the more the merrier
especially when like you have the
financial means right oh my god imagine
like not having to worry about like
another kid like another tuition it's
just like it's like an Instagram post
not even it's like an it's sort of story
right so I hope that they do and it I
was watching some old Kardashian's
yesterday and it's really crazy how like
in one year they had three girl
granddaughters like within the span of
months now what do they have now eight
like oh my gosh I named them okay okay
in birth order no no not an amazing
reality reign yeah and then North
actually North might be older than me
okay that's not true in birth order
Mason Penelope rein North Chicago Saint
true Remi
dream dream counts dream is the only
Kardashian actually all right nine
that's a terrible name dream and you
know what I'm so surprised at them like
I know that celebrities do weird names
but like I don't know I like I don't
know I just I I thought they were like
different well I feel like for Kourtney
she's very like or no he's a normal name
Mason's a normal name rain and then
kinloch has to do Kanye means like they
have to be on another level like why
couldn't have Khloe just done like true
death no we're like jasmine Tim I don't
know like a [ __ ] regular name well
they do have an ancestor name true oh
that is true and it's just like hard
with their names like I can never
remember is there a boy a boy or girl
right it's true true so girl see that
gives so much more of a boy rain is the
one yeah sure because no it's not even
the name I look I see a picture of rain
I'm like boy or girl because she grows
the hair out is Raina boy or girl I
think rain is a boy
I think Wayne's boy too and stormy is a
girl see they're both like those are
gender-neutral names which is the future
right so they're on the cutting edge
once again okay good third story about
our favorite man I want to know how
you're feeling about him since like
everything's going down Elon Musk
scraps plans to take Telsa Tesla private
he's [ __ ] losing it I know but like
and you know what is just the most wild
thing ever
why is that the most like the smartest
most innovative genius of our generation
was taken down by Azealia Banks I'm
sorry she was really like she brought it
down like he was ready on the down with
the tweets about the Thai boys but like
he could have made it past that of
Xillia bangs took down Elon Musk I just
I can't and I don't want to give her
back that was faction because like she's
so sleuthy and I think it's like not
right what she does because she uses her
celebrity to like be mean to people but
she brought him to like it's her I'm
sorry she gets credit for it she
definitely gets credit for it but
honestly I didn't follow the whole story
I saw the beginnings of it and I'm still
teeny on like I want I eat Lankan bounce
back from this he's losing me no I I'm
no longer a college it's a Jew is like
finish the Hyperloop the flying cars and
then like our worlds will change forever
and he
we'll be like the Tesla you know what it
is 2018
this is what they say on Shark Tank
there's a difference between being like
an inventor a genius engineer and being
a business person yeah you really very
very very very very few people are both
you just have to embrace the one that
you are like I'm not creative I'm not
like a genius I'm gonna I'm neither but
I'm a bad example I feel like we're each
a little bit of both yeah but like when
you get to a certain level like you
can't do it all yeah and I think a while
ago he should have like brought ins like
a Mark Cuban whereas and he could just
focus on finishing the Hyperloop and
building that weird thing yeah hi boys
like he is an engineer he's not a
business he needs that he needs to see
and maybe he was too cocky to do that
but it was definitely his downfall I
don't think it's over yet for Elon like
I think I think he can bounce back he's
like right now we really don't have that
many great minds I know it that's what
that's why retain us and like scientists
but that are also like well-known I'm
sure there are but we don't know that
right but like I feel like it's been a
while since we've made a really big
advancement you know yeah like we're
still using highways from the 1800's
we're still using train tracks that PT
Barnum laid down and like honestly I'm
ready for the next generation of
transportation and infrastructure
I cannot believe seriously like we
haven't figured out a way to cure cancer
yet like what we see our time let's go
right and then there's a conspiracy
theory they're like we really can do it
but like then like has they're not
forcing people to like buy all these
medications and stuff so right my suit
achill companies like they have the care
but they're not sharing it but I refuse
to believe that anyone is that evil I
agree but I'm speaking of cancer
do you watch you there no okay so
someone ruin the affair for me I said I
don't see what happened
I went see what happened I probably
won't ever watch it but just in case
don't say no I won't say about because
they're people maybe hope not soon
season I'm not gonna spoil anything but
someone ruined it for me so I was like
really not inspired to finish the season
but I did and like what she ruined was
annoying but like there was so much more
and me and then stayed up till 5:00 in
the morning on Friday finishing the
season and it is the single greatest
season of television in a while like of
any show I've seen Wow like it is
unbelievable in the beginning was really
slow and I'm like I can't watch this
because what they do it's really it's
like interesting what they've done from
the beginning is that the episode is an
hour and the first it's divided into 30
minutes in 30 minutes and each person
gets their own 30 minutes but sometimes
you'll watch like the same 30 minutes
from one person's perspective from the
other person's perspective and it's like
interesting to see what changes like
this woman brings she has shared custody
with her husband and the husband has a
wife so she brings the cake to the
birthday party and they're like don't
worry we already have a cake so in her
perspective she brought this beautiful
grand delicious cake and then his
perspective she had like some little
shitty cake and he was like don't worry
we already got it it's like those little
things are interesting but like to watch
the same birthday party from two
people's perspective for a kid it's
stupid
well if shutter island' taught us
anything it's all about perspective of
course so that's what you do that if you
would like it actually maybe I'll watch
it's a good show to start because it's
like you can take your time I just
finished catching up on unreal which is
the show about the professor and I guess
what it happened it used to be on
lifetime and now I'm realizing that Hulu
picked it up and the fourth season is
literally so hard to watch like the
protagonist rachel is the worst woman on
TV I've ever seen yet this show is
supposed to be like feminists and moving
the ball forward it's winter running the
show and like the way like I just I
don't understand what they're trying to
accomplish with the show like because
she makes like women look so horrible
that's so weird I didn't know that it
got canceled I don't know if they got
canceled or something but then I wanted
to download the last few episodes for
the plane that wasn't on iTunes was only
on Hulu I'm like it must be a Hulu show
now well so I think that one shows get
canceled and like other networks or
streaming services like pick them up
like Arrested Development like actually
I feel like it's never good it's weird
that sixth season of Arrested
Development was like some of the worst
television I've ever seen and I think
they came up with another one I'm not
watching it unreal
Nashville a community community it's not
a good thing like
I guess it shows they cancel for a
reason yeah oh my god the Royals got
canceled did you hear that
I don't watch Mitch and I are so upset
and the season finale of the last season
made no sense like and we're like the
only thing keeping us going was what's
gonna happen next season right but I
mean it makes sense because like the
director be fine so happy about it
they're so funny I know the director of
Royals mark Schwahn who also did OC in
One Tree Hill it's like a big molester
so um I guess it made sense why it had
to get shut down oh my god that's crazy
there's gonna be no television anymore
because like everyone who's in a
powerful position
men are just like molesting people and
they now they're being honorable yeah
Argento or argentina i couldn't keep up
with all of it there cuz i didn't have
good service no and also it's very
confusing
it's very think these guidelines about
her are so crazy I need NT to spell it
out for me me too I need a full search
because I know nothing also John Doe by
I know nothing John Doe he came back did
you say din literally the next day came
out he was like I'm sorry I have to come
back oh my god thank you Joe and also
John Doe promoting the toast in tune
with on seminary he's he or she is I
forget how literally long you've been
gone I know I missed so much yeah
nothing at all cuz I could pull stories
and there's nothing here your panties
this next story I pulled for you because
it is everything we've ever wanted I'm
so scared what is it Cesar Millan do you
know what that is the dog the dog
whisperer teams up with sling TV for
national dog day they are launching a
show shows your dog will love pic by
Cesar Millan it's dog titi I have to
break your heart it's dog TV Joey I have
to break your heart Suzu Milan it's like
super controversial what yeah like see
there's some footage or some [ __ ] about
some of his techniques that are like
yeah bad
are you sure before I'm special ringing
I'm not sure but I know people now that
I say people in comments will tell me
the truth but okay so you know that my
building is wired for the most weird
cable company and they offer to talk TV
but you have to pay extra it's like
Showtime I'm like [ __ ] I'm not paying
extra for dog TV but this is amazing
like we always say we need to on TV for
Theo because like one he could stay home
and you could leave drunk TV on and he
would just be having a great day yeah
and but when you put the TV on Theo
pretty much falls asleep even if it is
like you're and here's a dog or a bird
chirp we were watching paradise and like
all the animal noises dude he's like
yeah that is so cute I'll caught up I'm
a [ __ ] is my life's friends it's the
only show he doesn't sleep he keeps his
head up and watches and when he hears
the law-and-order dun dun yeah he knows
he knows he knows what's up that videos
my favorite video of all time yesterday
we had a nephew sneak chess day in and
it was just so nice he was two together
we watched bachelor in paradise which
was four hours which and then we watched
him Kardashian's and he was like so
there I think he's a big Kris Jenner fan
did he like the couch because the couch
I'm considering getting is the same as
Jackie's to be like he loved it he was
she was sleeping in all different areas
he was nestling between the pillows we
there's good but corners and little
things like like nooks and crannies for
him to get into he was very he was a
happy boy and he uncle Sonny just let
him in the house and everything was
great and he'll definitely be getting
invited back so Cesar Millan's content
that's gonna live on sling TV that's so
sad no one will see it it's a it's a
partnership for dog TV and I hope this
just you know spurns like a whole
new dog genre see kind of stupid no but
like Theo like if you let like leading
Theo in the crate is so sad
nobody left the TV on for him anybody
still fall asleep I used to leave
classical music on for him because like
when you are pregnant if you play
classical music like your baby could be
smarter so just thought like it might
work for Theo Theo needs all the smarts
he can get no offense totally lacking
he's a beautiful but he's not the
smartest thing sharpest tool in the shed
I think all the money resources that
this streaming company is putting into
dog TV when like they could just give
like a tenth of it to us and we can put
on the number one morning show ever like
come on
right well I think it's more so like a
coup for them to celebrate national dog
day
um but yeah it's a little stupid I agree
but we always talk about dog TV yeah
because it is like a good idea
what was Secret Life of pets where like
that mood been really want to see it and
I really like seeing cartoons like that
one seems stupid
have you seen Coco no I heard it was
unbelievable oh my god I didn't need to
see it me too because AJ was talking
about it and it sound it was so funny
like what yes dang like I don't know if
the movie study but just the way he was
talking about it so now I have to I'm
inspired to see it even though it did be
great a showman for best song at the
Oscars chaos Idol was robbed wait what
song isn't it
some stupid remember me I can't I
literally can't even with award shows
these days so you went to one I did um
sorry me and TPG pre kept it on Thursday
so when I texted you all my questions
yeah and I won't double-dip because it's
annoying for people but it was an an
epic experience I'm so happy for you I
can't leave you didn't see Kylie for a
picture even though she was taking a
picture of someone else okay so ready I
was literally Samia TBG got up during a
commercial break to go got to make sure
and someone had was to have like just
ask her for a picture right in front of
me I was like waiting and waiting and
waiting I'm like this person was taking
forever I'm like I wasn't gonna be rude
I'm waiting on me maybe then they could
record me see the Khmers break was over
and they made everyone sit down and then
the Kevins and he was like literally all
over the place like she it was so weird
her do you would you watch it a little
bit I watch a little bit I catch him on
it when I'm home on a Tuesday night her
and Wow
the only two there they were like
they're together and it was kind of
weird Wow sucks sucks
that's what here's noise I got a picture
with him yeah hard for me to keep up on
the cast members but she while seems
like a fuck-boy yeah and I like the
brunette that he dates and I like the
blonde that he [ __ ] over no I don't
like her that girl from Long Island
she's so incredibly annoying she never
talked about for our friends yes but
honestly like I go back and forth with
Hannah and just like Chief shoes in
general
like yes she was being super hard on her
but like this girl straight up like lied
that she never worked on a boat and they
took a picture so we're on a catamaran
like a boozy brunch like that nuts
what's called like a screams like that
is annoying and like everyone the kind
of sandy being like oh whatever like no
that is annoying saying she had silver
service experience like I don't know
that is but like oh I thought about that
but Hannah's out of control
she is like I kind of like her and when
she got into a fight with her boyfriend
about like their lifestyle that is so
weird it's like she loses me every
season when she starts to date someone
because she's crazy but what I'm just
it's hard to separate like to work
staffing the Charter guys Jason and like
she read and they found the text on the
iPad that was crazy
and that is like so real cuz like iPad
iCloud realness is a problem that was a
great season oh but did you see they're
bringing back oh gee
yes Caribbean with Nona Caribbean I'm
they're going in the Caribbean with
Captain Lee yeah I thought it was
something better than Caribbean I'm
pretty sure it's Caribbean I remember
seeing gonna be like oh that's such a
good place and and someone one of the
people falls off there's a man overboard
yeah I think right there's always like
one thing that like happens I'm like oh
ho anything in the real it's like not
that big of a deal yeah always like
Captain Lee was crying captain Lee is
the best okay Chloe we have to get
through all the stories because we're
gonna be closer and closer to March day
we hold a new location 34 minutes till
merch is available for premium toasters
patreon.com slash morning Tahiti that's
what I thought that in the Caribbean
they go from the Caribbean to Tahiti
which is like French pot like Polynesia
everyone Bora Bora
cool yeah right yeah that's pretty
anyways our fifth and final story is
just about Bethenny and Dennis she
tweeted last night for the first time
it's hard to breathe and I appreciate
you giving me the space and support to
try to do so it's excruciatingly sudden
death is no closure and constant
questions and memories a relationship is
current so it's painfully raw trying to
stay healthy and move through it with
tears and close with tears and close
friends EXO I love her my heart breaks
for her this is the saddest thing and
watching the reunion now it's like she
already was in such a too hot and it's
like things got so much like you think
that that was bad things got so much
worse so I didn't listen but someone did
a whole recap of an AJ Benza podcast I
saw and AJ Benza said that Bethenny is
really close to losing custody of her
kid and if that's true like I will not
be okay
but like it could not be sure because I
don't know proof yet but he
clothes my physical in the place like we
wouldn't just say that I agree I see him
having Cleese friends I'm like really
like just rot over Bethany and the
watching the reunion has been like
really hard for me because like I can't
even put into words why it's so
upsetting and like I think that the most
in-depth we've ever gone which is our
episode recap before the boat which
still rings true everything we said I
stand by but like just going in on it
like I can't Dorinda is first of all the
hair oh my god Claudia Giovanni Giovanni
honestly this is some of the most
incredible press for Giovanni because
people literally all over New Yorker -
screaming Giovanni no like I literally
saw a woman in a shimmery dress when I
was in the Beast I was like Giovanni
right it's just there's too much going
on in Luann's absence is really felt I
mean like Sonja's not enough for bet
like so I'm used to working overtime to
defend Bethenny but they needed one more
like heavy hitter to have Bethenny's
bath like when Ramona just goes you and
your fake tits like what's the [ __ ] is
not it like and and he's getting a lot
of [ __ ] for being like very Pro Bethenny
but here's what me and TPG said and I'm
sorry for repeating myself there were
two instances where Andy intervened and
people are saying that he's now crossing
the line into like taking sides but when
they were saying terrible things about
Bethenny being an opportunist filming at
Bobby's aren't stupid
I'm glad shamaton no he said not that
I'm glad we saw he said Jill reached out
to us and asked us to film the funeral I
mean happily did so Bethenny would never
show up to a funeral with cameras so
that [ __ ] put everyone in their place
and that's not taking Bethenny side
that's just stating facts that help
prove Bethenny's point right but it's
true but then he was a little biased
when Ramona was like well then you're
talking to her outside with cameras on
and and he was like good I'm glad you
did I want to see that but about when he
had to intervene I was subjective that's
true my point but I always say this what
I said to TBG every couple years
something so terrible is said or is done
at a reunion and and II have to
intervene with Phaedra basically
accusing can't kandi of date rape like
that was so atrocious like Andy did take
a side at some point like when things
and like what's going on with Bethenny
is so unfair and so unjust and so
immoral that like I don't blame Andy for
taking like a little bit of a side for a
moment you know what I mean no I totally
agree and then the second time you
intervened when he was like look perf
stink and
sure it has something with Bethany ants
to do with the fact that literally she
couldn't [ __ ] talk she didn't say
like more than a minute of sentence in
in the reunion last night Tinsley didn't
say they didn't Sony didn't say anything
it was just Carol Ramona and Dorinda
screaming screaming screaming they think
if they say a million things and thrown
up straight at the wall and don't let
Bethany speak people are gonna think
that they're good people but they're not
Bethany looked amazing oh my god the
updo and the dress like I'm not a big
updo fan but oh my god she looked I
think this is the best she's ever looked
so and you looked incredible - oh my god
I want everything that all are showing
in my centimorgan same and what I was
saying to TBG I'm sorry that I keep
repeating myself is that a lot of people
like a random Facebook groups have like
uncovered that like her [ __ ] is like
sold at Target for like half the price
but I would buy from Sonja Morgan's just
to say it's Sonja by Sonja Morgan
because the two things I've seen her
wear bought shop inside that pink rose
dress and now the reunion dress just I
worked at synchros dress and I'm happy
that she finally is like I feel like
that that really helped like her
business get off the ground I don't know
if it actually helped but like it seems
like now they're best friends in the
business is surging button is booming
yeah and Ramona love to get to I'm not
crazy about her hair her dress is pretty
and the bruise thing was so funny oh my
god because when they sat down I was
like that's not how I saw it in the
commercial right and then it made sense
that makes like that was actually really
funny um Carole I'm not a fan of her
dress whatsoever I'm not a fan of
anything and and Dorinda the dress was
fine but the hair oh my god she looked
just like a blackjack dealer in Atlantic
City like she just looked like I can't I
don't even know also all the woman's
hair was like yellow like her hair was
yellow Tinsley I was yellow same thing I
think I was thinking it might have been
the lighter it might have been but like
you've been on TV for a few years now
like your hair is yellow
what Tinsley said about her haircut was
so funny like I'm completely finished
with her but like every now and then she
tastes like a pearl of wisdom I'm like
maybe I'm not done with you what did she
say I thought cuz remember how Kara was
like a haircut yeah I just like I
thought cutting my hair would make me
feel older and fatter but it actually
made me feel younger and thinner I
thought the same thing
girl of wisdom I like when she's not
trying so hard she's actually like
really cute and sweet but her like being
up carols but like has done her no
favors and I hope Carol leading the show
forces Tinsley out of her shell a little
bit right cause like sometimes she's she
acts just like so fake and like annoys
annoying but there are moments where
like we actually see like who she is
she's just like having a conversation
yes she's like ditzy and like cares
about her makeup and stuff but like
that's cute like she could be a cute
cast member and like I think she has the
potential to bring something to the show
that isn't there which is like this
young fresh like new mom like she wants
to be a mom millennial you know like
coming quick it was what Kristen taekman
was supposed to be yeah she just turned
out to be so goddamn annoying that my
husband was a Madison oh my god I was on
the asteroid he's also mean to her on
the show yeah but that's like what's
going on with Tinsley he's got he dates
other people that's crazy also he lost
so much weight
uh he's such a catch and like I can't
explain it like I think he could you
better than translate I'm sorry like I
know that they're cute together all that
stuff um but I'm just like he found like
a nice Jewish girl in Chicago yeah but
um
Tinsley I didn't love her dress but the
hair was really no but I didn't love her
dress last week she they're gonna have
great style she's very specific waspy
preppy nobody did
style you guys anything that's made by
Allyson Olivia tell South Shore it and
then just like she doesn't care what it
looks like it's all this like she'll
wear it if it's made by them yeah I
wonder if any of the ladies do Rent the
Runway do you know what I mean cuz like
these are Union dresses you can never
wear again
someone TI me that the company they
worked for made Bethany's dress so
obviously it was cut symmetry she's rich
as hell or they could just go to
Giovanni right but like you can never
rewire it but it's also nice to have it
to the memory in the memory but I would
rent the runway every time earlier I
doesn't always have like the best and
most current choices I could it's more
for like prom and going to formal wear
in college like these women are real
yeah and every reunion is like the
dresses are like the dresses of the
moment it's like a moment in time right
but like they're member of the dress
that Dury wore to the gold party was
shackled in her hair like that was an
epic like that with the Cape
yeah like that was a dress of the season
when remember of your house was in Miami
probably not Audrianna wore a sparkly
short sleeve mini dress that was made by
Parker and I weren't to a wedding the
next I know that yeah it was like a
dress at the moment like they wear
current dresses they like set trends I
agree also there in the end I remember I
forget where Kyle Richards was talking
about this oh maybe in one of the like
behind the scenes housewives thinks how
they got here she had a dress in her
closet that she wore to a reunion and
she was like I will never wear that
dress again it was a horrible reunion
for her they really need to make a real
house eyes Museum yeah and like the
clubhouse is like a little bit of it but
with like the bear and all the dresses
and all these like iconic
Allison Dubois ecig like yeah that would
be so cool yeah it's like we're just a
Bravo Museum when you have a dress you
like wore to a funeral of like some like
like a painful like not like a funeral
you went to as like someone's friend
like you're like your personal circle
like you can never write that dress
again it's like the same thing with her
you know yeah but less traumatic right
and also like even if they haven't a
good experience at the reunion like you
still can't it's on TV so much like it's
over even though LuAnn lessees and were
the dress that she wore to her
engagement party which is so bizarre get
a Giovanni
go to Giovanni we gotta go to Giovanni I
know when looks amazing I think we
should do a podcast episode with
Giovanni the Joe of Giovanni but points
gonna mean two excellent points about
LuAnn one he said I'm and I never even
crossed my mind but now that he said it
kind of makes the sense like I'm
wondering if they'll bring her back
because at some point like it's not like
a liability and it's like a moral thing
like Kim Richards almost like even
though she's just late because they
brought her back after she shoplifted
they'll bring LuAnn back to Kim Richards
back after so many heart remember when
she shoplifted that target yeah but that
was when she was off the show right good
thanks she came back on the show
well like years later no she was
literally on the show for so long just
until like two seasons ago she was on
the show when erica was on like what
what I've been hearing just you know I
have deep sources inside Bravo is that
in order to film like any show
especially reality show you need
insurance and with just all like the
weird things happening in the housewives
onra it's getting increasingly more
difficult for Bravo's to secure
insurance and you can't film without
insurance so I know and another thing he
said about LuAnn which is a really good
point that I never thought of cuz like I
really I'm on the NCI I want her to be
sober but he made such a good point it's
like now this is the second time she's
gotten out of rehab and she keeps doing
the same things it's like when you're in
recovery like you have to change it up
like you can't hang out with the same
people and go to the same places like
because it reminds you of what you used
to drink so she's like out in the
Hamptons with the same people going to
her show doing the same show I'm like
yes I know she has to make a living but
like how could it's hard there is
something that was opposed to rehab the
first time around which was good yeah
and I mean Wow as long as she's not
going to Palm Beach and the Regency
yes I think and the baccarat Hotel I'm
so on Team LuAnn meet I mean I'm on Team
LuAnn that's me
and I just told you Antonia of course
but I've always loved showing it and I
just love when like when my horse wins
the race checking I couldn't agree more
because for some reason it's not there's
no rhyme or reason you get attached to a
swipe and you just like continually take
their side even they're wrong wrong well
sometimes I don't take their side when
they're wrong but I just see their side
and like I understand why you acted like
an [ __ ] but let's make it right right
and you're not like excusing the
behavior you just refuse to hate them
because of it right and so there's no
door exactly those are the first few
seasons when she had her [ __ ] together I
didn't like her them and she was nuts
you liked her and I really hated well I
just did I understood like how she was
like that so crazy like yeah what her
husband did to her was like so [ __ ]
sad yeah and that she was so honest
about it and I don't think any other
house is as honest as Shannon beador
agreed but there's no better feeling
than like retribution right that's how I
felt about LuAnn because honestly when
she became friend of housewife people
hated her and like yes she was doing
annoying things and I really did hate
her but she came from Bethany and said
she was dating a married man but I
always really liked her and now she's
like she's achieved icon status a green
and I'm really happy about it
agreed also while we were talking about
how sighs I just wanted to talk about
one other's show but I can't and Shen to
remember so what else is on these days
Oh see I have not caught a bachelor I
can't I haven't started Dallas oh dalsu
this is what i wanted to talk about
beverly hills filming in the Bahamas yes
lit as hell I just started falling Dury
by the way I didn't follow her before
she posts premium content because see
what you did
Justine Marchand does her hair and takes
epic pictures for her did you see what
she did what did she do so I put up that
meme of Kylie when she's like reaching
back for the phone right and though oh
yeah and then I was like if your
photographer doesn't like take so many
pictures of you that you're begging for
your phone back like it's not a good
photographer she literally to wreath
took like word-for-word I didn't make
the mean I just reposted it from someone
else I forget who it was
she took word-for-word what this meme
had written and like use it as her
caption like as if she wrote it herself
honestly good for her because that's
like so sorry that's so relatable and
she had we all have that picture totally
I had that picture like three times a
day I mean oh I thought it was I thought
it was cool that she did that it shows
that she's in tune the footage it's just
so funny how like when the housewife
stay at a hotel as opposed to like a
house so much gets out like it really
behooves Bravo like spring for a house
because they were staying at her hotel
like every time they had dinner every
time they were at the pool people were
videoing them taking
I'm selecting everything I know
everything I know if someone came up to
greet was chasing her around the pool
she's going around the pool being like
you and your husband oh this guy
$300,000 like I don't know what it was
about but their finances are really
shady cuz like not that it's bad but
like they read their house and just for
the level of fame and money that they
say that they happen to have like you
wouldn't rent your house and they did
all this renovation on their house after
season one of her hurt after her first
season and they like acted like it was
their own renovation like they put their
money into it but like the owner of the
house did well I feel like they ran
because they're like transplants and I
don't think they intend to stay in LA
for that long like they were in Miami
when they weren't filming like before
last season and like maybe they'll go
back to like the UK it's all weird but I
I really like her right now also Erica
is on the show when Darren was here like
someone had said in the toasters that
Erica like wasn't gonna be on this
season or Darren alluded to it yeah but
she is Thanks I look stupid uh Denise
pitchers is there looking exactly like
Teddy Mellencamp this is gonna be
confusing I'm really not here for Denise
Richards I just feel like we were in
such a good place sorry I'm not I'm not
not here for didn't Denise Richards I'm
not here for like the famous people
being housewives I would like household
names because point to the two points
guy and he was like Lisa Rinna was
famous before I'm like honestly as
someone like a my age like I'd heard her
name and I knew her hair but a no idea
like who she was or what she was about
no but like I think in the most famous
you could be when they brought on Lisa
and Eileen like I really didn't like it
for like until three seasons later when
they were just housewives to me like
when they came on like talk about their
Emmys like it's it's weird and I know I
don't feel that way about Eileen a
homegirl is hardly famous before Mike is
no but like to us to the people who
watch housewives as people watch soap
opera actually know like I'm not here
for traditional celebrities becoming
housewives except but like granny Brandi
Glanville was like the perfect housewife
because she wasn't a celebrity but she
her name was in the news because of her
husband and LeAnn Rimes so like we knew
who she wasn't me wanted to hear which
is these four turns is like a working
actress and it's just like I don't need
an actress on my reality show because
now I'm gonna think you're acting but
apparently Charlie Sheen like makes a
cameo be so weird that would be so we
I'm not here for it I think a lot of
this is gonna be four million why I saw
that and there's some ways and she
probably won't even be interesting and
there's no housewives who are out here
like it's like working like Lee Allen
Leeanne Locken probably
ten grand an episode because there it's
a new franchise and she's starting out
but like Denise Richards who's gonna
suck
4 million I could just distribute that
wealth to like 10 other housewives I
told her I'm gonna like Beverly Hills we
were in a place where things were just
about to burst like we didn't need a new
housewife yeah we could have brought all
the old [ __ ] into the new season because
it was just getting good at the weigh-in
the linemen like not nothing really
happened this past season but then like
all the stuff between like Vanderpump
Lisa Rinna was being really quiet oh
yeah Erika and Teddy had kind of buried
the hedge so maybe like something would
have blossom from there
the friendship between Erika - Ari and
Lisa Rinna was everything oh yeah Kyle
was starting to get a little pissed with
her Padma but I was in says they really
need to bring back Eileen because she
was the first person to really ever like
question Lisa bana from from like the
second she met her and not pretend like
everyone pretends like Lisa
I mean Erika Jayne does not like this
Vanderpump but she pretends cuz she's
smart Eileen never pretended I really
could use Eileen back on the show and I
could use Lisa off was Lisa in those
videos yeah was she yes she were all
taking like album like mixtape covers on
the beach yes and it was amazing I'm so
excited I really could live without Lisa
Vanderpump
me too but she's just a necessary evil
okay so it's 11:40 so we got a rap
because we got a go launch our merch but
reminder 12:00 p.m. Eastern Time
patron members get access to March
honestly it's worth just becoming a
patron just in a month just so you can
get access to much but if that's not
feasible for you five p.m. Eastern Time
set an alarm the rest of the merch is
gonna go live so make sure that your
degree in the store on Instagram Lincoln
I'll be able to find it you're not gonna
be like hard-pressed to find it don't
write it'll be everywhere you look um
thank you guys so much
have an amazing day and we'll see you on
our store
you